[Musique]
il
et tous
ce jardin n'est pas
[Musique]
c'est
rires et chansons
s'ils veulent nous
[Musique]
2 x 2 cela fait cela fait pas grand
chose je continue ainsi de 3,3 deux fois
crois ça fait déjà
c'était un peu plus ouais ouais deux
fois 4 al assad deux fois 4 onces à
sable on fait rentrer les 6 es un con
les 87
bon je vais vérifier avec ma règle à
calcul oui ma règle à calcul pour ça
fait rien je je je pose lui tape je
retiens 12 cela me donne
cela me donne l'âge du capitaine
alors qu'est ce que çà et là ça m'a
l'air très sérieuse que tu fais là tu as
les devoirs à faire pour demain matin
non non pas du tout je prépare mes coups
mois pour enseigner à l'école de l'île
aux enfants depuis colmar sur ce tableau
je vais enseigner le calcul la géométrie
et la pifométrie la pifométrie la
pifométrie qu'est ce que c'est j'ai bien
reçu pas très forte en mathématiques
mais j'ai jamais entendu parler de l'art
de la pifométrie non c'est normal c'est
une science tout à fait nouvelle dont je
suis le génial inventeur
bon je t'expliquerai ça plus tard pas
t'asseoir tu seras ma première élève
alors je pose 8 jan ravageur qui a 12
ans quand j'obtiens sorte qu'un l'âge du
capitaine
qui a dit ça c'est moi qui me retient
bien est-ce que ça en tant que vous
arrivez en retard est déjà assez grave
que vous soyez sans mon excuse mais
qu'en plus ça vous signez la
perturbation ça devient intolérable
julie qu'est ce qui arriva casimir il a
l'air de très mauvaise humeur
françois je ne supporte pas que l'on
touche à pendant les cours
alors qu'on est bon contre ayons un
cahier et un niveau à soir oui monsieur
si on commence à
le convaincra il fera passer les virages
et je trace en rond on ne dit pas est
rond mais un cercle qui a dit ça c'est
moi monsieur on ne dit pas héros mais un
cercle et les françois fortin journée
c'est moi c'est toujours pareil on ne
vit pas on est un cercle et puis d'abord
c'est un carré sortais je vous avait
pourtant prévenu comment s'appelle cette
aux figures géométriques un aiguillage
se croit aucun dieu il me semble que
c'est un carré je crois pour tout un
train très bien j'aime ça vous aurez 0
ah ça c'est haro par exemple enfin je
veux dire à serques julie sortait pour
beaucoup tu veux bien casimir mais tu
n'auras plus d'élèves et et tu ne
pourras pas savoir si taux courts est au
point non mais c'est vrai je n'ai pas
pensé pour ma alors si toi elle ne veut
pas qu'ee pas nous appelons françois et
les enfants ils vont aider françois les
enfants venez voir qu'ils étaient donnés
les enfants nous allons essayer d'aider
casimir a trouvé le nom de certaines
formes géométriques très bonne idée
regarde casimir voilà
qu'est-ce que je me reconnais moi c'est
une boule dont casimir très bien c'est
une sphère
alors quand je joue à la pétanque se
joue ans farah
si tu veux casimir auch tu as peu près
compris
bon enfin de toute façon la géométrie à
à côté de la pifométrie c'est vraiment
très facile très facile la vie sous les
tricks et sexuelle oui c'est après
casimir une science très nouvelles dont
il est le génial inventeur ouais et
alors et bien casimir vu tes
connaissances en géométrie d'une
permettra d un petit peu méfiants quant
à cette science que tu réinventer
mon pauvre françois tu fais partie de
ces gens qui pensent que la terre est
incomplet alors que tout le monde ça
calais boulic sérique enfin la terre est
bien composée de deux émissions deux
hémisphères quasi meyrals on ne vous
chamailler pas françois loos casimir
expliquer sa fameuse pifométrie enfin je
vous dis comment veux tu que je
travaille dans une quête par atmo
semoule de métro qui veut sans doute
dire une atmosphère défiance françoise
un gentil casimir nous écoutons aller
alors la pifométrie il est une science
qui permet de deviner des figures et des
volumes géométriques les yeux fermés
parfaitement je vais vous faire une
démonstration
cash et moi les yeux avec toi bien là
casimir là tu ne vois pas je ne vois
rien parfait maintenant prenez ce
plateau je commence la démonstration
bien ceci est un cylindre de chez bras
ceci est en rectangle de pouline éclater
leur étant de pont l'évêque ne pas
confondre avec le carré de l'extension
ceci est un cercle de camembert ça c'est
une magnifique bull dans l'orne
et pour terminer un triangle de bris
voilà c'est fini
[Musique]